vous êtes tous près
de la montagne et un christophe les
étudiants etc what you there c'est moi
qui l'avais prise est bon les hameçons
oui d'accord bon voilà on y va allons-y
suivez moi
alors je les revois renchérit des
travailleurs voire tout à l'heure au
revoir
comme vous le voyez le jardin est très
calme maintenant c'est étrange
bien sûr si c'était comme ça tous les
jours ce sera un peu triste mais une
fois de temps en temps c'est c'est
reposant messieurs du snob françois et
casimir sont partis à la pêche et ils
ont emmené tous les enfants avec eux
pour vous dire la vérité je suis très
heureuse d'être seul pour une fois
j'aime bien casimir est monsieur du
stade mais ils sont tout le temps en
train de se disputer et il m'empêche de
ranger mon kiosque si vous saviez il est
dans un état épouvantable
excusez moi il faut vite que je me
dépêche d'aller ranger mon coeur
tiens un mot pour moi
julie j'ai une grande surprise pour toi
tu la découvrira en haut de l'arbre
rouge signée casimir l'arbre rouge
il n'y a pas d'arbres rouge dans l'île
aux enfants
puis moi j'ai du travail de patente
je voulais quand même bien savoir ce que
ça signifie voyons l'arbre rouge j'y
suis c'est comme ça que kazemi rappelle
la cage à poules bon je n'ai plus qu'à
grimper là haut
sally pas facile du tout
à
je suis mal parti
nous y voilà
bon ben maintenant il faut que je trouve
la grande surprise
moyon
mais c'est étrange et julie n'est pas la
gelée oui oh oui oh qu'est ce que tu
fais là tu m'as fait peur je suis venu
chercher ma boîte d'hameçons j'allais
oublier mais mets toi mais qu'est ce que
tu fabriques laukyo mène au mont par le
passé c'est un mot que casimir que j'ai
trouvé dans mon coeur me disant que
j'allais trouver une grande surprise
pour moi en haut de l'arbre rouge et
c'est bizarre ça va casimir m'a pas mis
au courant et tu trouve quelque chose
non ou pas pour l'instant cherche un
bien à temps voilà un petit moulin
dit du duvet de gentils du tube one le
livre nous
écoutent vraiment ils exagèrent tu ce
parce qu'il n'écrit non bravo julie tu
es de plus en plus forte
comment vas tu as envie de la hat et
roncq ou à l'éducation
c'est pas très méchant quelle farce est
d autre chose mais oui
notre brave emile fait ça pose où est
caché le troisième message mais que la
terre est basse bombe écoute un
troisième étage quand je n'ai pas le
temps il faut que j'aille ranger mon cas
julie julie tu attends
revoyons sacré coup notre brave emile
fait ça pose où est caché le troisième
message
je crois que j'ai compris viens avec moi
le message doit se trouver par ici
exactement comment ça ce commet pas du
tout
aujourd'hui c'est simple il sait très
bien que emile campagne notre recteur
tous les jours fait une petite sieste
sur sedan avant de terminer sa tournée à
l'autre au civil amitié récent
ensuite mais que la terre est basse donc
dont casimir veux te faire comprendre
que le message trouve au ras du sol aux
radios
nous sommes là et dire que j'ai tant
travaillé que sont en train de faire un
signe de piste et aussi je tenais
casimir j'ai dit ça y est j'ai trouvé le
troisième message mais heureusement que
tu es là parce que bien longtemps que je
me serais décourager oubliez pas de
raison mais je trouve que c'est un jeu
très amusant à du trou eh bien je les
vois que ça mais pas toi qui arrange le
casque donc je t'en prie ou non veux-tu
connaître la grande surprise remy bilan
en marche j'écoutais mon premier est le
contraire de haut
mon second est le contraire de cours et
ma surprise est au milieu de mon tout
mon premier le contraire de hauts et ses
bas ses bas mon second est le contraire
de court
ses lois et mon toit au milieu des
badauds mais ballon mais bah non c'est
les ballons et dans les vallons pourra
le voir dans les vallons vite
julie doucement cicta mais je dis aussi
tu vas me crever nous nous jetons non
mais ça y est ça y est voilà le dernier
message non à mécha gens comme moi
jamais assez jean-thomas vocale et chez
les bettencourt pour avoir la fougueuse
détenir le message de tout cas si vite
commencé trop en colère lit le toit
julie bon
bravo juline associés gentille eux mêmes
puisque parfois j'espère que tu n'as pas
vu passer le temps je savais que tu
t'ennuies ray sûrement sans nous alors
j'ai inventé ce jeu de piste pour te
faire passer le temps plus vite